- I really needed to turn
over the reigns to Bob,
to someone else.
- [Narrator] That was Robert Iger in 2020,
when he stepped down as CEO of Disney,
the company he led for 15 years.
Two years later, he's now back,
after the board ousted Bob Chapek
following weak fourth quarter earnings.
Disney stock rallied
after the announcement.
Bringing back a CEO is a
strategy that many companies
have attempted over the years,
some more successfully than others.
This is how three so-called
Boomerang CEOs made comebacks,
in how their company's
fared after their return.
- A former CEO can help
revive a company's culture.
They're often viewed as
the face of the company.
They often have inspired
the hearts and minds,
a lot of people sometimes say.
Bob Iger was someone that
while he was not a founder,
people have described
him as a quasi founder,
in the sense that he was
a larger-than-life CEO.
- [Narrator] Like Iger,
Howard Schultz was considered
a popular CEO at Starbucks.
He first stepped down as CEO in 2000,
but returned in 2008 as the
coffee chain's sales slumped.
After cost cuts, Schultz got
Starbucks to profitability.
By the time he stepped down again in 2017,
Starbucks' stock was up 640%.
But when he returned once more
in 2022, on an interim basis,
he found a different company,
facing worker dissatisfaction
and pandemic consumer shifts.
- I came back to reinvent
the role and responsibility
of a public company at a time
where there is a cultural
and political change.
- [Narrator] Starbucks has said
that it will invest $1
billion into employees
and store experience.
- A returning CEO or founder
has to come back to a different company.
So remember, someone
else has been leading it
for usually a couple of years, at least.
That means the strategy has often shifted.
So Spencer Stewart
looked at across all CEOs
that were appointed at S and
P 500 companies since 2010.
And eight out of 13 permanent
boomerang appointments
did worse during their second stint
than during their first stint.
- [Narrator] Twitter's
co-founder, Jack Dorsey,
was fired in 2008, in part
for frequent absences.
- The board brought him back in 2015.
They basically wanted
to reassure investors, and the hope was
to revive the social media
company's sagging user growth.
- [Narrator] During his second run,
some employees said he
acted too slowly on issues
like hate speech,
harassment, and censoring.
Dorsey left the CEO post again in 2021.
During his second tenure,
Twitter shares gained 63%,
while the NASDAQ composite
more than doubled.
Twitter and Dorsey did
not immediately respond
to request for comment.
When he left, he said in a statement
that founders leading companies
can be severely limiting.
But founders like Dorsey
are common boomerang CEOs.
- What we often see is that
CEOs who are either founders
or really connected to companies
feel that it's their duty,
their service to make sure
that the company succeeds.
One of the most prominent
examples from the late 90s
is Steve Jobs coming back to run Apple
when it was on the brink of bankruptcy.
- [Narrator] Jobs first
left Apple in 1985.
He returned in 1997 as an advisor,
and eventually took the CEO title.
- I, like a lot of other people,
are pulling together to help
Apple get healthy again,
and I am extraordinarily confident
that that is gonna happen.
- [Narrator] He quickly
brokered a surprise deal
with Microsoft, sending the stock up,
and he brought Apple back to
profitability within a year.
By the time he stepped down in 2011,
Jobs had helped turn Apple
into a smartphone giant.
Apple did not immediately
respond to a request for comment.
As for Iger, he now has two
more years at the top at Disney.
Investors hope he can turn things around,
despite the company's tumultuous year.